[Musique]
j'ai grandi dans un environnement
violent
j'ai appris la colère et la violence
des fois cette fuir un contexte très
violent un contexte aussi de la bulle
[Musique]
Vic un vaste territoire dans le Grand
Nord que leurs ancêtres ils nous ont
apprivoisé en développant des
compétences de survie exceptionnelle
mais on les a brutalement arraché à ce
mode de vie aujourd'hui c'est beau
paysage abritent beaucoup de familles
brisées
[Musique]
de la nourriture et de l'air frais de
son village la mère de quatre enfants a
quitté le nous n'avait qu'il y a 7 mois
avec son bébé
essuie une thérapie pour traiter son
alcoolisme et apprendre à gérer sa
colère elle a fait plusieurs séjours en
prison
ne me parlent même plus à cause de ma
colère et de mes crises j'ai vraiment
besoin de changer de comportement
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'impression d'être au travail
ici c'est vraiment beau de voir cette
communauté là arrivé de France il y a
trois ans
a eu le coup de foudre pour les
Premières nations c'est des rires c'est
parfois des moments un peu plus
difficiles qu'on traverse tous ensemble
il a suivi une formation pour devenir
intervenant dans ce refuge pour
itinérant autochtone presque tous vivent
avec des traumatismes liés aussi vis
subis par leur parent et grands-parents
parfois les seules choses où elles
trouvent pour survivre c'est d'être
violent d'être dans l'alcoolisme la
toxicomanie c'est pas du tout quelque
chose qui vient comme ça il y a des
raisons il y a des traumatismes derrière
comme elles savent pas quoi faire
d'autre elle transmettent ça à leurs
enfants et leurs enfants voient ou leurs
petits-enfants voient que ben voilà les
les adultes
c'est normal d'être comme ça d'être
violent d'être intoxiqué de pas savoir
communiquer
à Montréal pour des soins de santé
fois par un centre de désintoxication ou
ici au centre de santé unique coincé
entre une autoroute et un parc
industriel à Dorval on a beaucoup à
réparer aussi la psychiatre Marie-Eve
coton travaille auprès des inouques
onunavik et à Montréal selon elle le
centre olivique n'a pas les ressources
psychosociales pour encadrer les
patients et leur traumatisme ils
arrivent à Montréal les substances sont
plus accessibles sont moins chères il y
a des gens qui vont leur proposer par
manipulation pour les exploiter les
rentrer dans des réseaux de prostitution
donc tout ça ça peut glisser ça peut les
amener à la rue il y a des réseaux de
trafic humain et trafic sexuel cible
vraiment spécifiquement les femmes
autochtones et les femmes inouïes en
particulier
[Musique]
un milieu violent elle n'avait pas
encore 5 ans quant à la été violée par
un cousin malgré tout elle a fait des
études collégiales et toucher un bon
salaire en travaillant dans une mine
quand elle est arrivée à Montréal il y a
11 ans elle n'a pas trouvé de logement
ni d'emploi et si la discrimination
était moindre envers les autochtones et
les Inuits
je pense que leur vie serait plus facile
ils auraient moins de chance d'aboutir à
la rue
de prostitution Maria a été
régulièrement frappée agressée mais ce
qu'elle a trouvé le plus difficile c'est
la peur et le regard des autres
des réactions teintées de préjugés les
famines où étaient autochtones en
subissent le courage d'aller à l'hôpital
après un viol à Montréal seulement deux
hôpitaux font des trousses médicaux
légales nécessaires pour prouver une
agression sexuelle dans la rue moi j'ai
plusieurs patientes que je vois qui
viennent me voir
je me raconte des choses épouvantables
de viol l'infirmière à niche Nabi
travaille dans trois refuges qui héberge
des femmes autochtones des projets
cliniques financés par l'université
migil elle a beaucoup de difficultés à
convaincre ses patientes d'aller à
l'hôpital ou le racisme fait encore des
ravages un des hôpitaux montréalais qui
désigne refusé de voir une de mes
patientes qui était pourtant accompagnée
de deux mes étudiantes francophones
parce que la personne ne parlait pas
français c'est arrivé pensez-vous que
c'est la vraie raison
l'impression qu'on a eu c'est parce
qu'elle était autochtone puis elle était
en état d'intoxication et notre
[Musique]
détournement 7 mois de se briété je suis
fière de moi je pensais ne jamais
réussir à devenir sobre à gérer mes
émotions
n'est pas complètement sobre mais elle a
fait assez de progrès pour être admise
en logement de transition ces deux
femmes ne souhaitent pas retourner dans
leur communauté où elle risque de
retrouver des milieux toxiques elle rêve
toutes les deux d'aider d'autres
familles nous qui autochtones à s'en
sortir
j'ai moi-même vécu beaucoup d'épreuves
j'aimerais les aider à avoir une vie
meilleure que la mienne
[Musique]